[inaudible].
So one of the propositions that I
set forth for you last week was that the most real things are the things that
are most permanent across time and that manifest themselves in the largest
number of situations.
And those are the things that you have to map successfully in order to survive,
survive as individuals,
but survive as a species over a very long period of time.
And so the question is,
one question is what are the constants of experience if you are a follower of
the evolutionary psychologists and to some degree the evolutionary biologists,
but I would say more the psychologists
like to be and caused meetings.
They have a very afro centric view of human evolution.
And the idea basically is that
after we diverged from the common answer ancestor between chimpanzees,
Bonobos and human beings,
we spent a tremendous amount of time in the African environment,
mostly on the Velt,
although we're not absolutely certain about that.
Um,
we're also very good in water human beings and we have some of the features of
aquatic mammals.
So,
um,
well hairlessness being one of them.
Uh,
women have a subcutaneous layer of fat or feed your quite nicely adapted for
swimming.
And so Buckminster fuller,
who I wouldn't call a mainstream evolutionary psychologist,
hypothesized back in the 70s that we spent some period of time in our
evolutionary history living on beaches near the ocean.
I had that idea really,
uh,
echoes for me because we like beaches a lot and it's a great place if you want
to get easy food.
And we're pretty damn good at swimming for terrestrial mammals and we are
hairless and we do cry salt tiers and there's a lot of evidence that we,
and our feet,
if you think about our feet,
they're quite slipper.
Like I know we all stand up and all that and walk.
So that's part of the adaptation,
but we're pretty good at swimming.
So anyways,
the classical evolutionary psychology view is that we spent most of our time on
the African Veldt and the critical period of our evolutionary development,
let's say,
after we diverged from this common ancestor and that were adapted for that
environment.
And one of the consequences of that is the idea that we're,
that things have changed so much around us,
that we're really not adapted to the environment that we're in anymore.
And I don't really believe because I think that the idea that the primary forces
that shaped our evolution shaped them during that period of time,
call it us roughly a 7 million period,
year period of time,
something like that.
And that that was somehow a special time for human evolution that set our
nature.
I don't believe that,
um,
I mean it's true to some degree,
but it's more useful to view the evolution of human cognitive processes over the
entire span of evolutionary history and not necessarily give preference to any
particular epoch.
And I certainly believe that the idea that we're no longer adapted to the
environment because of our rapid technological transformations is simply not
true.
And the reason I think that it's not true is because the fundamental constants
of the environment,
let's say,
or it's more of the fundamental constitute constituent elements of being.
I think that's the right way to think about it.
They're the same.
They haven't changed a bit and there's no way of changing them as far as I can
tell without us being radically and in comprehensively different than we are and
you know with with the rapid rise of artificial intelligence and robotics and
all of that,
it's certainly possible that in 500 years will be completely will be.
So like unlike the way we are now,
that we won't even be the same creatures.
I don't think that's a particularly great outcome,
but it's certainly impossible.
So what are the fundamental constituent elements?
While they're expressed in mythology,
but they're,
they're not merely symbolic.
I think it's the wrong way to think about it.
They're symbolic,
but they reflect a very deep reality and they actually reflect the reality
that's not easily apprehensible directly by the census.
Now your senses are tuned for a particular duration.
That's roughly,
excuse me.
Oh,
that's roughly the duration that you live,
let's say.
But more importantly,
it's the duration,
whatever that duration is across which meaningful actions take place.
And we kind of have some idea of what that duration is.
You know,
if you look at us,
a computer screen,
if it has a refresh rate of less than 60 hertz,
you can see it flickering,
but above 60 hertz,
you can't,
it's uniform.
And with movies,
um,
anywhere between 20 and 50 frames a second is enough to give you the illusion of
continual motion.
So,
you know,
we live in a universe that's above the 10th of a second domain or maybe the
hundredth of a second somewhere in there anyways.
And I mean,
it's not like time isn't almost infinitely sub dividable at higher levels of
resolution than that,
but we don't operate generally speaking at higher temporal resolution than that.
And then,
you know,
we're,
we're our,
our,
our feeling of the,
of the felt moment seems to be,
I would say something approximating half a second to a second,
you know,
um,
I mean,
it's an estimate obviously,
but the second is a meaningful unit of time for a person and a hundredth of a
second really isn't in certainly a billionth of a second isn't.
And then,
you know,
we can think across hours and days and weeks and months,
but we really can't,
once you start getting out in two years,
it gets kind of sketchy and it's hard to think more than five years down the
road.
And the reason for that is that the particulars upon which you're basing your
predictions are likely to change sufficiently over a five year period.
So that extending out your vision past that just exposes you to accelerating
error.
Right.
And that,
and of course that's the problem with predicting the future periods.
So we live in a time range that's about say a 10th of a second,
two,
three,
three years,
something like that.
No,
I know it can expand beyond that,
but that's,
that's kind of where we're set and our census seem to be tuned to those
durations and,
and to be operative so that we make proper decisions within those durations and,
and also from,
from a particular spacial position and so forth.
You know,
your eyes see what's roughly,
maybe we could say a walkable distance in front of you,
something like that.
So I knew didn't detect things and in the locale that enables you to immediately
interact with things,
but it isn't necessarily the case that senses that are tuned to do that are also
tuned to inform you directly about what the most permanent things about being
itself are.
I think that those things have to be inferred.
And there's some,
there's some supporting evidence for that kind of thing from uh,
from psycho linguistics.
There,
there is a level of,
of categorization that we seem to manifest more or less automatically or
implicitly.
So for example,
when children perceive animals,
they,
they perceive at the level of cat or dog.
They don't,
they don't perceive at the level of subspecies like Siamese cat or,
or,
uh,
let's say salmonoid,
you know,
there's,
there's this,
there's a natural,
I can't remember what they call that base category,
something like that.
It's usually specified by very short words that are easily learnable.
And so the linguistic system seems to map right onto the,
to the object recognition,
po characteristics of the sensory systems that are built right into it.
And,
and if they weren't built into it,
we couldn't communicate easily because our natural categories,
I think that's it,
but it's probably wrong.
Our natural categories,
they have to be the same for everyone or it would be very difficult for us to
communicate.
Okay.
So having said all that,
then the question is,
well,
what are the most,
what are the most real categories?
And I think there's,
there's a real division in ways to think about this because there's a scientific
way of thinking about it.
And,
and in,
in that case,
the most real categories are,
well mathematical equation certainly seemed to be in the top category there,
their equations that describe the physical universe,
but then then the hypothesis of the existence of such things as protons and
electrons and you know,
the,
the material elements that make up everything.
That's every element of being with the possible exception of empty space.
Um,
but in the,
in the mythological world,
the categories I think are more derived from Darwinian by the effect of
Darwinian processes on cognitive and perceptual function.
So which is to say that we have learned to perceive and then to infer those
things that are most necessary for us in order to continue our existence,
propagate live well,
all of those things.
And that would be true at the level of individual survival.
And maybe it's also true at the level of group survival,
although you know the,
there's a tremendous debate among evolutionary biologists about whether or not
selection can take place at the level of the group.
Anyways,
there are these basic level categories that manifest themselves to you.
And then there's categories of the imagination that you have to infer up from
the sensory domain.
And we do that partly in science by comparing our sensory representations across
people.
But we also do it by thinking abstractly,
conceptualizing abstractly.
And no,
one of the things that's interesting about abstractions,
it's not clear whether they're more or less real than the things they're
obstructed from.
You know,
this is a perennial debate among,
let's call them ontologists who were interested in that fundamental fundamental
nature of reality itself.
In some sense,
independent of conceptual structures.
Our numbers more or less real than the things they represent.
It's a really hard question to answer because knowing like using numbers as a
representational system gives you unbelievable power.
And there are mathematicians that believe that there isn't anything more real
than mathematical representations.
Now it depends to some degree of course on how you classify reality.
That's the problem with a question like is a uh,
equivalent to be the answer to that always is,
well it depends on how you define a,
and it depends on how you define be.
So generally it's not a very useful question,
but you can still get the point that there's something very real about
abstractions incredibly real.
Because otherwise why would you bother with them?
They wouldn't give you any handle on the world.
So what's the,
what's the most useful or what's the most,
what's the broadest possible level of abstraction and is there any use of any
utility in thinking in that manner?
And I tried to make the case last time that,
that in the mythological world there are three categories or four depending on
what you do with the strange fourth category.
Cause the fourth category is sort of the category of uncategorizable entities.
And so it's sort of the category of everything that not only do you not know,
but you don't know,
you don't know what it's it's,
or you can think about it as the category of potential.
I actually think that's the best way to think about it is that it's the dragon
of chaos is the category of potential.
And I do believe that we're,
our materialist view is essentially wrong.
I think that the proper way of looking at the,
at beings that being his potential and from that potential,
whatever consciousness is extracts out the reality that we inhabit anyways.
That's certainly the mythological viewpoint and,
but it's not just a mythological viewpoint.
It's,
it's,
it's the,
it's a,
it's a sequence of ideas,
for example,
that deeply underlies the thinking of John Piaget and Piaget.
By the way,
it was very interested in reconciling the gap between religion and science.
That's really what he devoted his life to doing.
And so,
and there are other streams of philosophy and I would say high digger that
phenomenologists are,
are thinking along lines that are similar to this as well because Heidegger was
concerned not with the nature of material reality,
but with being as such.
And so you can extract out the viewpoint that I just described from mythology,
but it isn't the only source of such,
um,
what would you call it?
A
hypotheses is probably the right idea.
So,
so the idea,
you can think about this as a bootstrapping process in some senses,
in order for anything to get going,
it has to bootstrap itself up and become more and more complex as it does that.
So it's,
it's like this is the answer to the chicken and egg problem,
right?
Which was first the chicken or the egg while neither something from which both
the chicken and egg were derived.
Right.
Cause the ultimate,
the ultimate answer to that is the answer to how there are things at all,
who knows?
But at some point there were neither chickens nor eggs,
but there were the things that were the precursors to those things.
And so they spiraled upwards in some sense.
And those,
those,
uh,
initial,
prodo entities,
single celled animals for,
we need to go back farther than that.
But we could say,
well,
single cell animals differentiated over time.
Right?
And there's this looping process that,
that differentiates out into both the chicken and the egg.
So,
but the question is,
what do you need in order for that process to begin?
And that's really the question of what the fundamental constituent elements of
reality are.
And the mythological hypothesis is that there's are three or four.
One is the fact that there has to be something that,
that,
that that manifests itself as an observer.
It's something like that,
some kind of observer now where that process of observation starts in the Fila
genetic chain is very,
very difficult to tell.
You know,
we might say,
well,
there's certainly nothing,
no possibility of a conscious observer until there's a differentiated nervous
system.
But then prior to the emergence of differentiated nervous systems,
there were animals that were complex enough to react with the environment in a
manner that,
well,
single celled animals,
they're quite complex.
I mean,
some of them are unbelievably complicated.
You know,
they can move themselves through space,
they can orient,
they can follow chemical trails.
They're not,
they're not stupid by any stretch of the imagination.
Now to what degree they have big,
you know,
as something that can represent,
well we don't have to speculate on that,
but the prodo elements of,
of conscious being are there.
So you need,
you need a being,
you need that.
The structure of that being through which the,
the entirety of being itself is interpreted and you need the surround.
It's something like that.
And so I conceptualize that as something that knows that's the knower,
what it knows.
That's the interpretive structure and that which needs to be known or you could
come,
you could conceptualize that as the individual in explored territory,
nested inside unexplored territory.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Or you can think about it as the individual inside culture and the individual
culture has nested inside nature.
That's another way of looking at it.
Or you can think of as the knower and in order surrounded by chaos.
That's another way of thinking about it.
But all these things,
you know,
they're all attempts to articulate the same underlying structure.